[Música]
economía en directo américa de france 24
nuevamente con luís méndez louis y vamos
a iniciar en ruso porque el presidente
de ese país anunció medidas ante las
sanciones y el bloqueo en los países
occidentales
básicamente el presidente ruso vladimir
putin indicó que estas medidas será que
ahora su país no aceptará más pagos en
dólares o euros por el gas que vende a
europa adicionalmente indicó que los
cambios sólo afectarán la moneda de pago
y que el gobierno y el banco central
tenían una semana para encontrar una
solución sobre cómo trasladar estas
operaciones a la moneda rusa a
diferencia de algunos colegas valoramos
nuestra reputación comercial como socio
y proveedor confiable los cambios
afectarán sólo la moneda de pago que se
cambiara a rublos rusos fue lo que dijo
el
presidente vladimir putin de acuerdo con
la agencia de noticias rusas interfax
pero esta noticia se presenta en medio
de lo que medios europeos como de
gharyan y también la vanguardia de
españa han manifestó como un regreso de
los días de la unión soviética cuando
empiezan a apreciarse largas colas o
largas filas para adquirir alimentos en
algunas regiones sobre todo las más
alejadas de moscú de acuerdo a estos
medios y el banco nacional de ucrania
pide más sanciones para rusia y es que
por la invasión a ucrania el referido
organismo instó al sistema swift a
desconectar el banco central de rusia de
su plataforma la medida busca aumentar
la presión y el aislamiento
internacional a través de un comunicado
kyrylo se opción con gobernador del
banco nacional de ucrania expresó la
petición a swift para que se una la
comunidad internacional y aumenta la
presión financiera sobre el estado al
que califica agresor esperamos su apoyo
y cooperación para salvar las vidas de
los ucranianos y preservar la soberanía
de nuestro país agrega este documento
este ha sido un largo debate desde que
inició la invasión rusa a ucrania y eeuu
la unión europea y canadá ya han
manifestado a la suspensión de rusia de
este sistema que respalda los pagos a
nivel mundial pero esta no es la única
petición que ha hecho ucrania sobre más
sanciones a rusia porque este miércoles
el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski pidió a japón establecer un
embargo comercial contra rusia pero para
entender un poco japonés un socio
comercial que importó bienes por un
valor superior a los 12 mil millones de
dólares en el año 2021 de acuerdo con el
ministerio de finanzas el gas natural
también los metales no ferrosos y el
carbón fueron los principales productos
importados por su parte japón exportó
más de 7 mil millones de dólares en el
año 2021 siendo los vehículos su
principal producto de venta noticias de
américa latina en materia económica
vamos a hablar de chile porque el
gobierno de ese país anunció un plan de
ayudas económicas para así acelerar la
recuperación louis no sólo acelerar la
recuperación esta medida también busca
evitar que sea aprobado en la nación un
cuarto retiro del 10% en los fondos de
pensiones de ese país
así lo manifestó mario marcel el
ministro de hacienda chileno que dio a
conocer la iniciativa durante una
comparecencia en la cámara de diputados
del y este martes el anuncio se produce
un día después de que la cámara baja
aprobará la idea de discutir un cuarto
retiro de pensiones anticipado algo que
ha sido rechazado por diversos
integrantes del gobierno actual bajo el
argumento de que también citando algunos
especialistas es que ésta ha sido una de
las causas de la inflación en el país
louis cómo están los indicadores cómo
están los mercados mundiales ante todo
esto los mercados asiáticos cerraron de
manera positiva sobre todo por la
expectativa que hay en torno a un
posible acuerdo de pasa entre rusia y
ucrania por otro lado los mercados
europeos mostraban números dispares es
decir números negativos a lo largo de
las jornadas se vieron impactados por el
alza del precio del petróleo y también
algunas noticias mientras tanto que en
eeuu los mercados abrieron ya con
números negativos sobre todo por el
precio del petróleo y también por la
caída en el valor de algunas acciones
louis gracias entonces por toda esta
información de economía nos vemos mañana
jueves con más nos vamos a parís ya esta
lista con toda la información